[Music]
Terri's with us in Clermont New
Hampshire hi Terry how are you I'm good
Dave how are you better than I deserve
what's up I have a 10 year old daughter
and she just recently got signed by a
modeling agency and I want to know if it
would be smart for me to do some kind of
savings or like either like a Roth IRA I
don't know if she's she's young for that
but some kind of savings we already have
a 529 in place for her that we put money
into every month and I don't want to be
dependent on her money because this is
her money and I want to make sure that
she is the full benefit of it okay and
the what what do you think she's gonna
be making if she has a really good year
the agency said roughly thirty thousand
oh my goodness not wonderful yes I was
very surprised well if she's gonna make
that much then I would use her money to
fund the Roth IRA that she earns and and
the rest of it you can bank all she can
do is $5,500 like anyone else can do
there's not an age limit on Roth IRA the
only limit is the you know once you're
50 years old you can put 6,500 but that
doesn't even come into play the only
agent the only limit is it has to be
earned income and of course she has to
file a tax return we're taking $30.00
yeah she's gonna be doing that anyway at
30,000 bucks for sure but you can do a
Roth IRA up to five thousand five
hundred and you would invest the rest of
it for her benefit and some good mutual
funds and what I would do is just tell
you to sit down with one of our smart
investor pros and get your hands around
you know what to do why to do it when to
do it that kind of thing with some
mutual funds on her behalf and I would
budget some of it for her to spend on
her now not a lot but she ought to
invite away some of it and I would but
she has your savings piggy banks then
she knows to give savings spend right
we're always in there or he's gonna give
some save some and spend something in
this case it's such an extreme scenario
for a ten-year-old to be making 30,000
that I would
just most of it okay and I would I would
have a little of it for play money and I
would encourage her to give some of it
and I just teach her to grow those
muscles and this could turn into a lot
of money if it's invested now and not
touched for you know 10 or 15 or 20
years I could turn into some serious
money here the Roth IRA money will turn
into a bunch of money and any of you
parents that have kids that are making
any kind of money like you know $1,000
$2,000 and above and you are able to put
some money in their name let them keep
the money they earn open a Roth Forum
file a tax return you can put up to
their earned income a maximum of 5500 so
some years I put 15 or 1,700 in my kids
name when they were eight or nine and
then I filed a tax return for them to do
that cost a little bit tax money a
little bit of money out of my pocket but
boy did it set them up well for the
future